Olha essa notícia que saiu agora e que
vai mudar completamente como você
enxerga a medicina. A inteligência
artificial já está diagnosticando
doenças melhor que muitos especialistas.
Pois é, não estou exagerando. Estudos
mostram que algoritmos já conseguem
detectar glaucoma, heimer, parkson,
doenças cardíacas e até diabetes com uma
precisão impressionante. Um exemplo, a
IA diagnostica diabetes tipo 2 com 89%
de precisão, apenas analisando a voz do
paciente. Isso mesmo, só pela voz. Veja
bem, o que acontece é que esses
algoritmos processam milhões de dados
que o nosso olho humano não consegue
captar. Eles identificam padrões sutis
em exames de imagem, alterações mínimas
no nervo óptico para glaucoma ou
mudanças imperceptíveis em
eletrocardiogramas. A tecnologia não
substitui nossa experiência clínica, mas
potencializa nossa capacidade
diagnóstica de forma extraordinária.
Então fica a reflexão, será que já não
está na hora de integrarmos mais essas
ferramentas do nosso dia a dia? Yeah.